let's talk about Jesus and the gays
because Elton John
has come out and said that Jesus is would
be down with the gays that's right
we've got a little video from the
interview the gym think the judge
I mean the church do you think it should
allow its clergy same-sex clergy to get
married
court and and and adopted by Catholic
priests have to be celibate
as crazy you know they these old and
stupid things I am
and the church hierarchy might be you
know
a up in arms about it the traditionalist
but times change we live in a different
time
China if Jesus Christ was alive today I
cannot see
him as the Christian personally he was
on the great person in the world
same this could not happen I'm he was
all about love and compassion
and forgiveness and trying to bring
people together and that is what the
church should be about
love and compassion and all that good
stuff could that be which eases was
really all about Louis
I I would say so yes I would also say
I'm at Taylor thing that struck me most
about this story was Elton John say he
wouldn't have a small wedding
I got shot bandages comments I was
mostly shot by him saying bad
you want to have a quiet small wedding
and not like a hologram Jesus actually
blessing the ceremony which is what I
would expect him to write I actually
really funny cuz you know he runs the
big Oscar party
here in West Hollywood after the Oscars
and its huge and over the top and
ridiculous but I just
yeah I mean I actually better than I
think fed now um
their money persons who who have the
same comment isn't the same points about
Jesus teachings and
I'm house away match what we hear about
in the book religious right on a regular
basis
yet so John this is your wheelhouse to
this is one here for a while
you know look I think Jesus would object
Elton John said listen concert I
whether the new stuff I like the Leon
Russell Albert do I have to wait three
hours to get to your side that guy
other boy of course he's right I mean
he's wrong about one thing that Jesus
was a Christian person Jesus
lived and died in June your arm but by
he's exactly right about homophobia is
an insult to God there is no passage in
the Bible
say this that thirty-year trolls your
there is no passage in the Bible you can
use to justify
any kind of LGBT discrimination any of
follow the medicare some Romans isn't
about gay people
arm II know all the verses very well
there's nothing in the Bible to justify
it so he's exactly right about that
he's also weighed about the Catholic
Church in celibacy the cap the
first putting peter was married all the
principals ambitions were married for
over 1000 years
was it opens at the second in 1139 e di
main celibacy the law
to keep recent popes from leaving land
in wealth to their children
so that was not because sex is bad now
because Christ was a bachelor because
the church
was greedy which means married priests
are technically
the conservative point of view that's
quite fascinating and how it's all free
base
soon dealing the church in a long-term
actually kinda screwed itself with all
this crazy sex stuff and the repression
in the case that that it worked for a
while
for many hundreds of years at work but
now we're getting to the point where
that stuff doesn't fly anymore and it's
actually turning people
more against the religion of course to
know it always backfires mean looking
into leaving the country where
are because the Catholic Church being
there they had no contraception they had
very few
teaches me that anti-abortion Mon at the
bush rate skyrocketed
not the death from Wasilla crazy because
they had no teaching about how to have
have a conversation in these things the
more draconian laws are the harder it is
to kind of have a normal
a safe life attacks the tree supposed
divorce
you know and again birth control not in
the Bible this is the same
this wall is the same reason why I we
have
the laws apply to kiss it's not about
holiness is about keeping your tribes
numbers up and they're becoming a third
world religion
and they're going into the third world
and saying your poverty is a gift from
God to get your reward in heaven
you can be developed this you're pumping
him out and the more more people you
have
were superstitious and agreed to keep
getting more babies the more
the more size your flock as and the more
you can police said flock
and its back it still works in the third
world its backfires big time in the
first world
yeah so units publicly supported number
right not to be really care with people
who supported ok that's about the same
do you think when Elton John says I'm
like this does any heart or mine get
change their cause the people that are
on board you think that actually effect
so so somebody that i think is a
believer
you think can actually hear that message
the burden is on them to explain why
Christ would oppose same-sex marriage
when he never said a thing against gay
people
and I could bore you with the you know
passages that I think prove that Jesus
had a pro LGBT
attitude the story the Roman centurion
whose whose
expertise with my house till my slave
and the apostles were so angry that we
know about the Romans historically
there under teenaged boy lovers on the
road yeah
the Greek the word is a slave in space
for beloved boy
so that explains why the apostles were
so furious Jesus
that he and why would a Centurion a VM
again taking the story literally
yeah words that are they wanted want
this and sure enough the Imperial
European occupying army seek out a
homeless
local Jewish mystics the peeler to come
into his home
to heal a common slave explains why the
apostles were so outraged because Jesus
essentially blessed a gay Union yeah
John taking the high brosser
Jesus had that's proving a hacer una
lowbrow
now is and also yeah months as do that
more reality television more
fixation teasers abstract Jesus exploded
really insecure
he totally does I remember to left on
this
so you know this new pope has been kinda
down with the gays and he's been to a
sourdough
its till you get a lot of pressure but a
little bit early but not at the same
time so
but but basically he kind of has said
let's get away from
talking the talk better than any other
pope I'm waiting for the walk to get
walked
yeah I assume same yes the same damn I
think that down
it's easy to kinda be happy makes the
same as they go viral on Facebook
but I don't know if he actually has I
mean here to carry through the TV star
to any meaningful way
yeah I love the guy and I hope he gets a
really good food taster I
yeah hopefully he will poking you acting
like this on
you can't thanks I saw die by the three
day but others yes